hello
i'm paul carling with film independent
and welcome to this week's coffee talk
uh for those who don't know us film
independent is the non-profit arts
organization our mission is to champion
creative independence and visual
storytelling
and support community of artists who
embody diversity
innovation and uniqueness and vision uh
we're probably best known for producing
the film independent spirit awards
taking place
on the beach in santa monica but we also
offer a
year-round programming of screenings
conferences
conversations filmmaker labs and
mentorship programs so
you can find out more at
filmindependent.org and membership is
over to all
uh we missed we took last week off and
so this week we're doubling up the fun
we thought we'd do a pairing of pairings
uh filmmaker teams so i'm really
thrilled to have
four great filmmakers with us today
first up they are the film making team
who took a long time to make movies
because they were busy making kick-ass
music videos for bands such as smashing
pumpkins
rem red hot chili peppers um
and when they did make their choice
movie it was the spirit award
oscar-winning
little miss sunshine which was a huge
one of the huge indie hits of this year
we followed that up with
ruby sparks the battle of the texas and
most
recently they have directed all eight
episodes of living with yourself
starring paul rudd which you can find on
netflix
so jonathan dayton and valerie ferris
welcome
uh hello hi there hi hi how are you
doing
good good you are in venice i assume
right
yes yes yes how's the knock down
treating you
well uh today is it's really good
one day at a time you know it be with
you know we have three children
and parents uh spread all over the
country
and so it's it's never just about what
your lot is it's always kind of a
juggling of everybody
daily checking in with everyone but
we're good
good and also joining us is the
filmmaking team behind
indie hits such as half nelson sugar
mississippi grind last year they joined
the marvel cinematic universe
and directed captain marvel their tv
credits
include episodes of the affair billions
and four episodes of mrs america
currently playing on hulu anna bowden
and ryan fleck
are both with us welcome hey ryan and
here's anna
no you are assuming i'm not in separate
rooms in the same place you are in
separate cities
right where are you ryan right yeah i'm
in um
i guess i'm in hollywood okay and anna
you're joining us from the east coast
yes
um in the hudson valley right now uh but
normally in brooklyn
okay and how's the pandemic
treating you both
i'm good i'm free i mean it's pretty
boring for me i think anna has a much
more exciting
story of her pandemic experience okay
you want to save that for the
conversation with john and val
well anyway uh the way this works is i'm
going to step off this virtual stage for
about 30 minutes and let the four of you
chat
and talk shop um all things directing
and filmmaking
i will come back to um field some
questions from our audience
if you are listening in and want to
submit a question use the question
button at the bottom of the screen
and we'll try to get to as many of those
as possible but uh for now is over to
the four of you take it away all right
hi hey hi so
so anna with that setup you have to
explain your
your exciting uh covid
i mean i don't know about i don't know
how exciting the pandemic's been for me
i mean it
i feel like for everybody it's kind of
um just been like an intense
stew of feelings but i did it
started out very personally intense for
me because i was
um my stuff was halfway between
los angeles and new york
on march 11th when i flew to new york
and you know was making this
cross-country move at nine months
pregnant with a five-year-old
and um and it was like a week before
lockdown
in new york city and uh so moving into a
new place
and trying to figure out how to give
birth during a pandemic
it was this real
kind of very focused
internal adrenaline journey
towards um finally giving birth on april
5th
and um you know i always think back to
that time
and like the amount of time between
march 11th and april 5th felt like a
millennium
and then it's just whipped by since then
as soon as i got to the other side i
feel like then i kind of
sunk into what everybody else had been
experiencing and um you know
like woke up a bit and
just um but grateful to be on the other
side of that
uh and now living through it like
everyone else
how about you guys well it is funny you
talk about that
the first few weeks i would say of the
of the lockdown i felt like every day
just was a a week long it just felt like
time was going
so slowly and i was just looking at
you know kind of how are we going to
make it through this day and we had
we had a difference that like our family
our kids are all grown up and they're
um in different parts of the country
when it first started
and one of our sons got coveted and
his girlfriend got it so being across
you know the country from him while he
was going through it was
agonizing so every day was just um
really long and and sort of torturous
and
and i couldn't get enough information
and news about it you know so i was sort
of feeding on
on all the information that was out
there but as as confusing as it was
um but then lately i've found the
opposite to be true now i don't
i feel like a week goes by kind of in a
flash
so my sense of time is really messed up
you know we were in production on a new
project
and it had to shut down and we spent a
while
trying to decide should we keep working
but it was like
fiddling while rome was burning you know
like you just can't
we just couldn't do it so it was kind of
a breakthrough
to just let go and say you know what
this we're not gonna work we're gonna
just stop kind of experience this moment
in
all its horror and you know frankly
not working was really nice and kind of
knowing that the whole world was
stopping
so that that was great i mean how how
about you guys i mean
having a baby is a surreal
experience under any conditions
but um but how like for ryan what was it
like
and you're it i'm just curious that that
that transition from you know whatever
you were doing
to just a completely different way of
life we
have basically been working so
relentlessly for the last three years
with captain marvel and mrs america
that all i had been thinking about in
that time was
taking multiple months off you know and
so
it basically was a forced time off and
it was great for those first few months
i was like this is exactly what i was
going to be doing anyway i'm just
catching up on movies i'm relaxing i
mean i had to cancel a vacation
and uh and a move you know i was gonna i
was moving to chicago actually
ended up in march and i got cancelled
we're sort of stuck here my wife and i
but you know we're in a comfortable
place it's uh
we're healthy and besides not going out
to
restaurants and movies which are some of
my favorite things to do
i'm kind of doing what i like to do most
which is
sit in a dark room watching movies and
writing sometimes
yeah it's almost there are times where
it's
you know i feel guilty because i'm
enjoying
the the quiet and the time to do the
things that i want to do that i've
wanted to do
like you say for multiple years but i
i it's okay i guess to admit it publicly
[Music]
but yeah well yeah and to like
appreciate
i guess like part of i don't know
recognizing that um
we're in this situation and that there's
so many people who are going through
something that is
beyond you know what we can imagine from
our position i feel like it's
important to recognize that
not everybody has such like uh
the ability to like sit back and then
enjoy
yeah you know but it's um
i think it's okay to like embrace it
and embrace the touch that you do have
yeah
and you know he's also staying because
he was about to
move to chicago and i had just moved out
of la he's like staying in my rental
house
that i had he just moved right in
so it just it does feel i think
like this bizarre
transitional you know we were caught in
the middle of a
transition and so it's not like we were
pushing straight through on something
like a production and i want to hear
more about what you were working on
um but it's not like there was this stop
right we were kind of in the middle of
this transition both work-wise
and in our personal lives and so it
threw us into a little bit of a strange
um a strange bubble or like
just moved us off into a different
direction they think creatively
too like you can't help but being kind
of
swung by that yeah
yeah you know it's interesting because i
know that
there's been so much talk about how to
make things in a time of covid and i
think that's
obviously an important question to ask
and hopefully
um there are some solutions i haven't
really
i mean no one has really come up with
something that makes
a whole lot of sense yet uh but i think
production in terms of production uh you
know
methods i mean it's just i mean if
you're doing we do commercials
uh sometimes and those seem to have a
little more of a chance to
make sense given just the idea very
focused stories that are told but um
but i i think that you know hopefully
speaking optimistically
this immediate stage of the crisis
will be different by the end of the year
i think we will i think ever
you know from everything we hear there's
you know
both uh treatments if you get it
and and the the vaccines seemed to be
very promising so
i think what's almost a more important
question is
what do we make uh
in a post coven world like what what
things do people want to see
what are you feeling i think that's the
question we are always asking ourselves
is like what it
what are we going to want to put out
there you know what is the world going
to feel like and i feel like
our our focus has been so much more on
sort of the way the
world is changing and or wondering how
is it really changing and
how do you gauge that but it does feel
like um
thinking about some of the things we
thought about before and even the
project we're working on you know how
has it changed by
what we've all been through and i'm
curious how you guys
um you know if you had projects already
set for the future are you rethinking
them
and are you um do they feel different to
you
yeah it is really interesting we get
sent scripts that were obviously written
before this but they're said in the
present
and it's like well deal with the present
anymore so the things that we've
actually been writing and looking at are
actually in the past because i have no
idea how to move
beyond this from a storytelling
perspective unless it's some sort of uh
future you know post pandemic zombie
movie or something
i only understand how to to look
backwards from this moment
yeah yeah what is the present day like i
i don't it is a kind of i feel like
that's every day i wake up
trying to figure out well so what is the
state of the world today because it
feels like it changes
daily um based on
you know it it's just sort of this news
is so shocking and reality is so
sort of dramatic right now that it's
kind of hard to imagine
how do you put drama into you know
how can you compete in a way with um
the level of drama that's happening
around us
exactly yes of drama in any
any realm you look at is there yeah
exactly
i have a question non-coded question for
you guys oh
and it's going to be annoying because
it's the thing that we get asked the
most
okay how about if we like i'll start the
sentence and you guys can finish
and then we'll just i think you know
where it's going yeah maybe maybe it'll
feel a little bit different
people are always asking how do we work
as a team
right and so like you know we
need a better answer is what he said
give us a better answer but like okay so
you get to set pa hands you the sides if
you're working on a movie or show
boom what happens what are you what are
you doing
well it's funny because i would have to
we'd have to back up a lot from there
because
i feel like um so much about what we do
is preparation and i'm curious how you
guys approach that because
um we we hate to argue on set it happens
sometimes but
part of the goal i guess is to make sure
that we have like
as close to a unified vision as possible
going in
so i feel like we probably do more prep
in some ways than
um a single director would
um but you know and then and then
there's also
all of the dga concerns about what do
you do on set i'm sure you guys have
have dealt with that where you can't say
oh well i go and talk to the dp and then
i talk to the actors or i go into the
wardrobe
trailer and you you can't say that
that you're doing it simultaneously yeah
you know like because the idea of
splitting
is is a very big issue for the dji and i
understand we're not here to
you know dispute that but but you know
so we both do everything that's one
thing we say
you know and and depending on who
uh sort of feels the most connected to a
a response i mean we're we're always
kind of huddled
together um and then when the take is
done
we'll just discuss briefly what what we
liked what we you know what's
needs attention and then whoever is sort
of the
most connected to that thought goes and
talks to the actor and
you know if we've been already engaged
with the actor we
tend to keep the same person going to
them but a lot of times like say on the
tv
series we did it was a lot of just like
the three of us
with paul yeah paul rudd or you know
whoever we were working with but
it's a lot of times both of us yeah
there um
and you know there's there's just so
much i always think
how does one person do this job because
it's just there's so much to pay
attention to and i mean that's
what i love about it because i think i
would be totally bored
on on a set if i wasn't directing
you know because i think the fun of it
is that there's so much
at any there's so it's endless how much
you can
um you know comment on or change
and um so i never get bored and i
i love that about this work um but
uh i don't know you know it's that's so
so
how does how does that square with
your practice i mean that is very
strangely
almost word for word at the same time
[Laughter]
so that wasn't helpful in terms of
material here
yeah damn but you know since we met you
guys
and um i i think in the last
12 13 years i feel like there are so
many more directing
teams and um and in a good way i
i don't feel like we get that question
as much and i feel like we don't get it
from the people we work with either
which at first i mean we started
before you guys and you know it used to
be kind of like
which one do i talk to we got that
question once from a
veteran actor that was um kind of funny
um but you know so there have were those
issues i would say more when we started
and um i think it's nice to see that
there are a lot of
teams now doing films and doing you know
all kinds of work and
collaborative like groups that that make
films together
so i think all that is really exciting
and
um kind of in some ways breaks down
the auteur idea of
filmmaking which i don't have anything
against that but i think that in
some ways teams are not seeing they're
like how do you
reckon with the sort of auteur yeah
well you know that's that's an
interesting question and
something unusual i wonder if it happens
with you guys
so often a misunderstanding will lead to
the third idea between us oh
we're like best ones are our
misunderstandings
i heard what she said and i was like oh
my god you like this
no that's not what i said but that's
great yes my idea it wasn't her idea
i would say that's that's probably that
is really fantastic
because that is definitely
a huge part of our which which wouldn't
happen
like you would never misunderstand
yourself
right maybe you've talked to yourself
enough i guess
but um i feel like you know that is one
of the things that we
love about collaboration in general but
also just you know that constant
dialogue and then the surprise of
sometimes it is just being surprised by
something that they
say that you actually do understand and
that is a good idea but
you know it's just that um that element
in way of the
um of chaos on some level it's a little
bit of
enjoying the kind of chaos of of two
people
trying to do something together and it
doesn't always
it's funny you say that because i've
never i've never thought of it that way
i always thought it was more calm
because
there's the strength in two people um
and i think that's true
in many cases but there is just a little
bit of a mini
like vibration that is very
alive on the set because we're both
having reactions and we have to
reconcile those we have to
and you know it is amazing when
well what i love is the strength in
consensus
like when we both have the same response
that's you know particularly with a
studio executive or certain
you know uh forces forces that
you have to reckon with and and and
you know when we are
one percent one front that's
nice helpful um do you i mean how how do
you do you guys
you you seem so like such lovely people
how are you
in studio like how have you had to fight
and how have you fought and you know
you mean between no no i'm sorry not
between the two of you right it was a
good opportunity for a misinterpretation
but uh with with you know outside
producers
financiers studios
i've always been you know been the
handful of times
when um yeah we've had strong
disagreements with somebody who is an
executive at a studio or producer
um and we've had to fight for something
but i also
do think that having to work things out
between the two of us
often stops there from being too much of
too much animus
between us and other people and because
we're so used to
just like working something out and
figuring out not
my idea your idea but what's the best
idea right right
yeah and so i think it it makes us a
little bit more
open than you know your traditional like
the directors i read about in books when
i was just starting out
who you know were always in a fight with
everybody
um yeah i i don't i don't
tend not to feel that quite as much a
little bit more
maybe on our first movie because we've
read all those books we felt like
fighting was a part yeah yeah well like
yeah i mean i
i i don't seek out fights and
often in a very natural way one of us
will be sort of
polarized and the other one in the room
will sort of be the bridge
between and and so there's it's never
you know it's it's always a changing
thing and it's very it's authentic i
mean we're not we don't come in
like strategizing our but we've worked
um we've done all of our films with fox
searchlight
so i mean the first one was was uh
independently financed and then they
bought it but we have worked with
kind of with the same group of people on
every film so they're
having which is great and having those
relationships and
you know but you guys how obviously
you've moved
in very different circles including
you know this very unique marvel world
how
has that been for you and and how have
you just
navigated that i think we've been very
fortunate through all the movies to work
with
like well kind people and good
collaborators
and so we've never had a tyrant
from above sort of insisting that we do
anything a certain way
it was always a conversation and i can't
say we always got
our way but there was when there was a
disagreement there was usually a
compromise
and i think that um like anna said we
don't really come in
saying it's it's my way or the highway
kind of we don't have that attitude
so i think that disarms anyone who will
who might have that on the other side
and we just come up come into a room
looking for the best idea and
uh often i think i think we work with
people and hopefully we find it
sometimes we don't i don't know
sometimes we come out of there with the
worst idea and but it's not like on
purpose
we just figured out later when you're
going to discover it was the hardest
idea like
um our first our first uh
few movies we did make with a very
intimate not not the same you know
distributor
um or the same studio they were
independently financed um but
the same core group of people same
producers
most of the same crew and it they were
very
um i don't just
intimate familial environments
and that had did change in the last
three years when we
worked on captain marvel and then mrs
america both of those
for the first time that we were um you
know
not working with that kind of core
group of people surrounding us who we
considered um
you know our collaborators that we grew
up
right right um and that does feel
different
i you know i don't know how
have you guys worked with a lot of the
same
you know not just fox searchlight but
dp and fbp
on everything and and you know we
we work with different dps on each movie
but
they were people we had worked with
either in music videos or in commercials
and you know had an ongoing relationship
and a kind of a healthy
collaboration but a lot of the crew and
um
the producer line producer um you know
we've worked with
uh that team multiple times and
so i mean that does you know that is one
of the things that right now i think
about a lot because i
i miss um that kind of that community
you know i i really and and i feel um
feel for them because they work uh you
know
by day by day more or less and
and so like just to think that a lot of
those people are out of work is really
um you know i i feel responsible on some
level like
i want to um get them back to work
um but but it is a real luxury to have
that and i
i wonder how that you know i think
marvel seems like from
everything we've heard from paul yeah um
rudd
he he loves that world i mean you know i
mean they well they seem to really know
what they're
doing they have i mean how how
you know i noticed that you that the dp
you worked with on that had done other
marvel movies and they
they do kind of have a look but how was
that being
did you feel that you were dropped into
that world um
could you you know how many of your
collaborators could you bring or how how
was that
yeah i think
um we didn't end up bringing
a lot of our collaborators on um
you know and there there were a few
people who on like to be perfectly
honest we would have really liked
to bring on um right but whatever reason
it didn't work out and it wasn't all
because they were like you can't have
that person
you know we um for
you know personal and family other
reasons
um our dp didn't didn't want to come
move to
la for a year to to shoot the movie
or equipment and you know being based in
new york and
so it and it was um
[Music]
luckily i'm just trying to think a lot
of the people who
they introduced us to
like our visual effects supervisor chris
townsend
and like ben davis our cinematographer
who
i would work with again in an instant it
was such a joy
like these were people who we you know
really loved and really
clicked with mostly
yeah and and
really glad to have had and
there was never um you know it was
there was so much mutual respect um
through that process
of making that um
of making that movie and these people
who had had so much more experience
making these kind of big movies and
working with visual effects
um it was it was always about like
trying to
get from us what our vision was so that
they could help
figure out how to do it and it was um
how to accomplish it and i think it was
a
it was an extremely positive experience
it's just that
if we do another you know small movie
we'll never be able to hire chris
townsend again right
right right yeah he'll never be able to
be part of like our core team
because he does these huge movies
you know right how was just that
that kind of a schedule and scale
of like how is holding all of that in
your heads and i'm just curious because
how many days was the shoot 75
yeah so that's yeah and how about just
the
tempo of work like you know
because that's one thing i really notice
from various particularly in television
where it's like oh my god we've got
seven eight pages to do today and it's
all dialogue and it's all
episode in a week you know but how
how is that varied from say marvel
and then for mrs america how was
that yeah that's good good question and
marvel was a
very manageable schedule like we were
shooting
you know a couple scenes a day it didn't
ever felt like it was overstuffed we had
time to do the setups we
we needed it never felt like oh man if
we just had more time we'd get this
we're also shooting 10-hour days i don't
know if you guys have experimented
we're just work through lunch and it's
it's you it's so much better
of a job yeah you you do work through
lunch that way
yeah yeah people are broke throughout
the day and they can go
they're not looking on the street yeah
they take it when they can
right right one sit down lunch where
it's last man
through um and it's really it's rough on
the camera crew who doesn't really ever
get them yeah
yeah yeah directors
but i much prefer it
and i do think it's it's just a better
in terms of a lifestyle
for the crew um
people the people who we worked with who
had experienced that even though there
tends to be like a lot of
union um
i've heard that there that the unions
don't love it
or not everybody wants to work like that
but the people who we worked with who
did work like that much prefer it
it's like you can go home and have
dinner with your family
be a working parent and not just
disappear for three months
to turn around the turnaround of of
having to your day get pushed back later
and later
yeah yeah we experienced that uh when we
were shooting in new york on
living with yourself and it was they
were not only long days but of course
they
they kept pushing but you know i mean
they were
new york was almost always 14-hour days
with
an hour commute i mean it was each way
it was sick
and and and and we had the unions coming
to our
set saying you just i mean
it wasn't our choice but we just in
order to make the schedule we kept
saying are you sure that the overtime
and all the
kind of costs involved here are worth it
and that we can't just
extend the schedule and work a few hours
i mean
did was television different free not
television but streaming
you know was were the hours different on
that project
you know we pushed for the same thing on
mrs america it proved to be
more challenging partly anna correct me
maybe fill me in here but the wigs
we had so many oh yeah yeah yeah and
wigs that we needed
that time in the day to break to get the
actor
to change first change over for scenes
because it was just too long so
uh funny yeah there was
it was a few things the pre-calls were
so extreme
yeah yeah yeah um
that it i think it
just would have been too brutal to work
through i for you know particularly i
don't know
i i can't remember if it was like a
canadian union thing because we shot
that
in toronto but there were a bunch of
different factors
we couldn't do it they do an hour lunch
into toronto
so it's a 13-hour day minimum and then
with all the pre-calls for hair and
makeup
to get the actors on their turnaround we
you know we were starting like you know
5 p.m by the end of the week and it's
it's really it's really tough on people
and i think it
it makes it i think it's it also
can be a barrier to um like inclusivity
in our field in terms of getting more
buried um you know diverse
crew into positions as it's
you know it takes over just limited yeah
take over your life and i don't know i
really do
wonder if there's something we can do
about that
yeah it's true i you know i do feel like
to the degree that this moment is a
reset
you know it is a good time to say well
okay
what what can we do how can we change
this
um because the one thing we also hear
which is kind of horrifying about
the very few projects that are shooting
is that
they move so much more slowly
everything's like they they they take 85
or 50
yeah you're going to get 50 of what you
expected the first day
and and you know so i don't know it
i think you know we we didn't have a i
don't you guys didn't did you do
consecutive
um episodes episodes or on mrs america
or
you did um did you block shoot you did
the pilot and then
we did the first two which were together
and then and then
um another director did three and four
and five and six and
sort of broken up that one that the one
thing that
i don't think is working super well is
when you
do a whole season you just block shoot
it like a movie
we did um because we had to because the
costs otherwise were you know with
certain locations probably but it just
meant that it was
two movies at the same time with very
little press
half the time i mean it was fun i i
you know we loved our crew and everyone
involved we liked and paul
was amazing but but it is it does beg
a question about like could this be
set up better yeah i mean it's a
different animal doing a
entire season of something and i i don't
know if
maybe if you uh i mean maybe
scorsese didn't have to do that when he
did
uh i know a lot of directors who i will
not name but
who take naps in those hour lunches
which good strategy i've tried a couple
times and i
gotta say it's kind of amazing it's
great
yeah you can yeah if you can squeeze it
in it's really it's huge
i'm not a big napper but i i want to
introduce that more
practice now yeah yeah it's good time to
um but yeah well uh
i you know and then we were also just
sort of curious how you guys
select projects and what that process is
for you
um you know does one of you do you ever
like does one of you read something
and um feel like ugh i really want to
make this and then the other one
doesn't agree or do you i would imagine
you generally
should gravitate to the same things but
i'm curious
yeah we've never had that experience
where some were
i don't think have we ever had something
where one of us really wanted to do it
and the other one didn't
no no not to that extreme sometimes i'll
read something and
be like hey this has something going for
it what do you think and then you're
like no
no you misread that
and i'm like oh okay um but yeah or if
you say you know read it again you're
wrong you read it again and then
and then we'll just fight over the thing
and we know then that's not the thing
right yeah yeah how about you guys
we're generally in in agreement also
um yeah i mean it's it i think
one challenge is finding things that you
have that
deep reserve for because it is going to
be
not just two years of your life it's
going to be
you know probably a couple years of
prep and development then you make it
and then it follows you around for the
rest of your life so you better love it
you know yeah i always say it's like
getting a tattoo you better love it
because it's with you forever
and wear it yeah yeah i you know like we
we just read a book that we really like
and we're now just trying to decide is
it something we could actually
you know we're in that part of the
process of
what would it mean to to take this on
and um
and and also you know like what would it
mean
how would we make this a film
and then how can we get someone to pay
for it because then we suddenly have to
become the
you know the advocates and you know
it's just we're not even to the how
would we get
someone to pay for it yeah i mean you
know when you
read something you also kind of have to
figure out how you're going gonna do it
you know like how do we see this and how
do we
and um that takes time i mean i how do
you
do you guys uh i mean when you're in
not in the same place how do you do that
or how how does it
and how much time do you usually spend
in development and writing
i mean there are two different kinds of
things right there's something that
we're gonna write and that's our like
idea that we're gonna
kind of start exploring
and by the way we'll start exploring a
lot of ideas that we
throw away before we ever even have a
first draft or after we have a first
draft or whatever
but and then there's things that you
know your
agent sends you and you read and um
you're trying to kind of insert yourself
into it and figure out
if you're the best person to make it and
if you're
you know you love it if you have that
reserve for it
um and and it tends to be
different and actually
i i don't know it that that process does
it never i don't think we've
ever really talked about this that much
so i don't have like
a really good sense of how to describe
how those two things are different but
it feels really different because i
think we only have the energy to follow
one of those things that we're writing
and starting
ourselves and then for reading
we can read a bunch of stuff and
entertain a few things until there's
until we get to the point where
we're like really serious about it and
we're not those people who have like
eight
things going on
and i really admire those people like i
wish
i i i i it's so funny we feel
exactly that same way is you know i wish
i could have a roster of projects and we
have
various things that are sort of in the
wings but
oh my god we can really only do one
thing
at a time in any it's not even fun to do
i don't like that um like juggling
uh stuff i just i think what is so fun
about taking on a project that you love
is that you
do really go deep into it and and
um and i like to be consumed by that
the thing so i feel like you just only
have
and and and if you have any life outside
yeah there there's the other there's
there's a life thing that happens
besides work but yeah which sometimes
gets
you know limited but i see
we have a fourth member on our fourth
screen up now
hi well that's been terrific um
i'm sorry i hate to break it up uh do
you have time for a few questions
sure yes yeah um some questions
have been you've answered already um i
actually had a question for you about
being a team because most most
filmmaking teams out there
are you know brothers or you know it's
like
two men two women how do you think being
a male female a team um
kind of brings a sort of fully rounded
perspective to your
projects do you guys want to start
uh sure i'll just say i'm very lucky i
don't think i would be involved with
either of the last two projects if i
wasn't working with anna so i'm uh
very grateful for that
huh but anything i don't know
yeah what do you have an answer for that
what do you guys say
oh um it is funny i mean i think
uh how like gender plays a role in
what we do and um i we're actually
working on
our project um with this woman ester
perel who's a
relationship therapist it's a
documentary series
with uh with her and so it's kind of the
first time i've
thought more about what we each
bring i mean i did i would say also a
little bit more on battle of the sexes
because we were really dealing
with um you know issues of gender
and and um women's empowerment
and so i was more aware but i think
because
i work with someone who um is
so not uh a sexist or
you know chauvinistic and really we have
such an e
even sort of uh
we're really well balanced i don't feel
that um
i don't think about like i'm
contributing this as a woman you know
here's my i have to do
my part as a woman or i don't know if
that's
yeah i mean it's just not on
my mind but it has been a little bit
more as the subject of what we're doing
um is centered a little bit more around
gender
i mean you you want to think that as a
creative person you can travel
and explore any subject you don't need
to be a murderer in order to explore
murder
but as you talk about gender and some of
in life experience
it obviously it does really mean
something to have lived certain
um experiences and and
face certain things so i lo i feel very
lucky that we have this
you know um range of
of experience that we bring right
yeah so i mean it and it's weird because
we are
married and have raised a family
together and i think that does
impact um but like you say i think
if you work together you get good at
solving problems together that's one
thing that
um i think is really great and why
diversity is so important
because i think you you learn so much
from working with people who
working with a variety of people coming
from different points of view i mean
that is what i love about film because
it's so collaborative and
um so i i think everybody brings their
own view but there's so many things that
um are part of that um
the perspective that you bring not just
your gender but
yeah good answer um i have a question
here
from an anonymous uh question
was asking and you did touch on this a
little bit specifically about giving
direction the notes to an actor
um do you do it together or is it one
person
that handles the
yeah for anna and i is a similar answer
to what you guys said which is
we um based on the relationship you know
sometimes just in the course of prep one
of us will develop a little bit more of
an intimate relationship with an actor
and
might have you know depending on what
the note is after a take when we're
doing that little huddle
if if somebody has a clear idea of what
that note is
and assuming we agree on it that person
will go deliver it what we try to do
is stay consistent with that person so
if we're doing take three four or five
that we're not like tag teaming like
nope that didn't work my turn let me try
it okay
yeah yeah like we try to get the same
voice
delivering the note so the actor never
feels like well i guess i blew it with
that
yeah yeah it is really you know it's
it's it's a dangerous thing to you know
to kind of to do that either you know
good cop bad cop
any kind of it just inconsistency
and you know but but i think a lot of
times
things that happen in rehearsal that
we're all experiencing
we can both go up and
talk about stuff and and it's
it's part of an ongoing dialogue that
we've all been having and it's
it's very organic it depends on the
relationship but i'm sure that's
happening with you or like
with some scenes or some
projects we just all three are part of
you know
we've got an understanding and so it
works for both of us to talk with the
actor
but um rehearsal really does help so
much i i
did want to talk to you guys about that
but another another time but
keep going paul what what what else
please talk about rehearsal
and like and also i would say and
working with actors who love rehearsal
and working with actors who don't
and when you have a mix of both where
some
need time to warm up and others up
knock it out of the park and take one
and you've got
both of those people in us in a scene
what do you guys think there's two kinds
of rehearsal right so there's the
rehearsal that you do
on the set where you're kind of working
and then there's the rehearsal you do
before
in prep yeah i i was thinking of the
prep rehearsal
yeah and and just you know
we we don't rehearse scenes in our prep
usually we just
kind of explore the character and the
tone
relationship and we try and get a sense
of what the actors
want and like and and how they respond
to certain things
um it's much more exploratory but
trying to get to the character or and it
helps us see
how they like to work and and what
and how they're going to work together
how they see the character and yeah
but and that prep has become
it's been harder and harder to get that
kind of prep time where it's like we had
a
a week on little miss sunshine and then
i think we maybe had a week on
ruby sparks and battle of the sexes we
had
meetings but not like the same kind of
and then we had a couple days of
rehearsal which
was really you know i i think because
prep time in general
on films has sort of shrunk we've
noticed that
maybe with lower budget films or you
know in
smaller films that kind of gets pushed
aside
and um prep is really just prepping the
logistics more um but i don't know
i feel like one of the the most
important things is
is creating a relationship between two
characters so that
they don't show up on the first day of
filming and go hi i'd like you to meet
your wife
here's your husband and now you've been
together and you have love
and you know you so in rehearsals we try
and create a little bit of a history so
that there's
some spark that that seems to resonate
beyond just the moment of that scene
but how i mean how do you guys yeah no
same it's saying we're not like
the rehearsal isn't okay you say this
line here and you move here
oftentimes and this is our go-to i don't
know how it'll be after kovic because i
can't imagine bowling again but bowling
was our favorite rehearsal is he
something to do
we took the cast of the sunshine bowling
there you go see i think
dating character they had to stay in
character the whole yes well that's next
level we weren't quite
but at bowling that's yeah that's great
it is yeah it's an activity it's fun
nelson
we did that for half an hour and really
a bunch of things since including
but i do like to read through the script
if i can and then
just like any questions that come up
you know make sure that everybody
you know is making the same movie right
basically
yeah and and that
[Music]
gives people an opportunity to ask the
questions
about the script so that they're not
asking them on set
yeah no exactly yeah and um
yeah really important and i do remember
like on half nelson we had
a week with um our two leads on that
movie
just hanging out reading the script
drinking like you know getting to know
each other so that there was a certain
kind of
and it was so important because sharika
ebbs um
the co-star of that film you know had
never acted before and had never been in
front of the camera except for our tiny
little
you know short film that we made with
the two person crew
um and it it was really amazing and it
is harder it is harder to get that prep
time now and you work with a lot of
actors who um you know have worked with
actors since then who
aren't that comfortable in that space um
and and you kind of pick up on that and
you know like uh
like you asked paul um how do you work
with
two people one who loves rehearsal and
one who doesn't
um you know i
i think that you um
it's less about like an on-set
thing for us we tend to if you have
somebody who loves rehearsal you have
them go second
when you have the cameras you're not
gonna overdo it on set
um for both of them but
if somebody you know you're actually
luckier if you have two people one who
really likes to warm up into a scene
and one who just is like sharp and
moving right off the bat
the trouble is when you have two people
that are good the first can't cross
cover them
and they're both best on the first three
takes
and how do you you don't know that it
always until
a little ways into the i think the movie
star will always decide that one for you
yeah yeah all right
question okay they're good
well no i just when we work with greg
kinnear his first takes were always so
amazing
and he he would hate them he would go oh
he's finished he goes i'm so sorry
like i don't know what i was doing i got
to do that over and it'd be like
no you're welcome to do it again but
we loved that you know there was just
sheer invention yeah
from laura she's sort of piggybacking on
your discussing about
uh selecting and choosing your projects
but she
asks how do you come to these projects
do they come to you via
agents or friends people suggest
projects do you
hunt stuff
sometimes it's it's an idea that we have
that's original and that we just want to
pursue and and
do on our own and everybody else can go
away sometimes an agent sends the script
and uh it's good or we think about how
we see it how it could be better
and uh or it's a book sometimes it's
just an article
but uh yeah yeah
yeah same for us it's and i love that i
love that
um i mean i i think we don't expect
to get scripts handed to us that are
ready to go um some you know little miss
sunshine was
pretty much the script that we first
read i mean we worked a little bit with
michael on it but
for four years yeah i mean just to try
to get it made but
but yeah it i would say it's the same
it's kind of
when that that sense of like oh this is
something that is
you know i want to spend time with i
want to and
it interests us it it's surprising where
those things come from but a lot of
times through friends
um actually people give us something
that
they think will like or you know so
but all over it's fine that it could
come from anywhere
that that that is makes it exciting
yeah a question from will er for
you ryan and anna just asking how your
partnership
formed your filmmaking partnership
i was uh i
i took a summer class at nyu and
um i met peop and
ryan had just graduated from the
undergrad program there and we just had
people in common we ended up meeting on
a
on a student film and um
kind of struck a friendship there and
started watching movies together then
started to help each other with our own
projects that we were doing
and we were so you know young at the
time i was
i was like 19. and it was just
us and a camera so we just started kind
of making short films and doing
everything together
and then we just kept working together
for the rest of our lives
that's amazing we value yeah we were no
we but you were
19 i was 20. yeah but that's
funny that it just sort of you know it's
it's not calculated or
like it's not just when you first met
you didn't say
we're going to work for the rest of our
lives together
but but you've always done projects
together right
yeah pretty much i mean half nelson was
the credit
is directed by ryan fleck but it was
sort of that time like you guys alluded
to where there was the coen brothers
and we didn't weren't aware of a lot of
other directing teams
yeah and so uh you know
i i directed that one quote unquote but
moving forward we were like well we
should really be
doing this together especially in posts
or even
in the release of the movie and we got
to see sort of how
the director is treated on right right
yeah
yeah interesting
you're pretty much out of time uh my
last question for everyone we would just
love to hear your
pandemic pics uh everyone wants to know
what you're watching and uh it can be
something like uh an old classic a
hidden gem
if you dig deep
ah you guys i bet i bet
anna barely has any time to watch
anything but
uh ryan before we started you said you
were watching a lot of movies i'm
watching so much i i would just have a
whole list here but
i besides you know living with yourself
which which i binged and loved of course
uh i this is going to sound weird like
i'm saying this because you guys are on
this but i've been diving into like a
lot of 80s music oriented
stuff and i did decline of western
civilization
guys and your names popped up and this
was just like two weeks ago
oh my god yeah i know when you think of
us you think heavy metal yeah
banging yeah oh that's amazing
yeah that that's a that was a fun
experience but yeah it
we produced that that was the only thing
we've ever produced
i had no idea and i was like dude these
guys
we were a year of our lives sunset strip
yeah but uh that's so funny let's go i
would love to see your list of things
that you're watching i
i feel like we we haven't we started out
watching a lot and
it was it's been a goal of mine to watch
the wire because i
never watched it uh when it was on and
and then i just heard everyone talk
about it but i never had the time and i
didn't want to just watch it
a little bit here and a little bit there
so uh
jonathan and i and my son watched
like the five seasons just dove in and
that was really the first
couple weeks of the pandemic and
i it was really incredible and seeing it
now
in in these times was really interesting
plus there's a podcast called
way down in the hole by jamelle hill
who's a really great
um journalist and um and a guy named val
latham who i didn't know but there
they discuss every episode of the wire
so i
that's really been interesting because
it's current so they're they're talking
about that in the
context of what's going on today
anything i know um i do
we'll admit i've been watching a lot of
um
movies that i can watch with my
five-year-olds and
because he's kind of just gotten to the
age where
i can watch movies that i wanna watch
with him i mean they're not
you know i'm not exactly watching you
know the verdict with him but
you know we watched tom hanks in
big we watched um the princess bride
we've we've watched all the original
star wars
and it's been really fun to introduce
him to
some of those movies that i saw as a kid
and really liked
some were hits some not as much but all
the ones i just mentioned
were enjoyed by all that's great you
know the other thing we've been watching
is
miyazaki because i don't know somehow
that was
the most kind of therapeutic those
movies like
uh you know our kids watched like totoro
and um
kiki's delivery service but but when
they were kids but then kids but now
they you know in their early 20s they
love them
even more and we watched uh two
documentaries about miyazaki which i
really recommend yeah they're so
beautiful i mean it's just i don't know
there's something about his love of the
natural world and then
but
yeah i it's really that was the most
therapeutic
thing we've watched i would say where
did the two documentaries play
once uh they're both streaming and
yeah the the uh kingdom of dreams and
madness
i think is on amazon and then
uh never ending man i think we had to
get off youtube
but they're great one of our guests a
couple of weeks ago
run was uh josh olson who's recommending
a ton of like crazy 80s movies
uh including the apple have you ever
seen the apple oh yeah
that's pretty crazy yeah that's fun yeah
it is wild have you seen that john
o'hall
no no i'll check it out the apple it's
all
uh pride made by
one of the the two the two guys that ran
cannon films in the 80s oh yeah sure
yeah
it posits a world where like one company
kind of owns everything
it's sort of weirdly it's on amazon
well this has been fantastic thank you
so much uh for joining us
um i hope you you know continue to be
creative during this lockdown and join
us when everything is back to normal and
share your next
projects with us but um until then
jonathan dayton valerie ferris thank you
so much
thank you paul and really great to see
you guys and um
hear you uh just confirm a lot of the
things that we
have felt about the process
yes thank you and then yes anna bowden
in hudson valley thank you anna
yeah and ryan flex thanks ryan
thank you guys
you